modify on create to create the location
entry database table using the constants
we defined in the contract the good news
is that this is a similar but simpler
statement than what we have in weather
entry you will be creating an executing
of string the stores in SQLite command
you'll want to make sure that you use
the correct data types for each column
also make sure that you have the right
constraints in general follow the model
of the weather table with the exception
of the ID all columns must be defined as
not null the location query should
additionally be defined as unique our
coordinates are real or floating-point
values you should consider adding
logging statements to print the SQLite
statement verify that it looks as you
intended play close attention to spaces
parentheses and commas once you have
finished writing the SQL to create the
table continue to run tests great even
within the test dB and let it guide you
as to how to fix your creation statement
once you have finished coding I
recommend looking at our solution just
in case our tests miss something